it's a pleasure to welcome back to the
program Charles durbur who's a public
sociologist and author of the new book
moving beyond fear appending the
security tales in capitalism fascism and
democracy and the title is so
interesting Charles because when we
consider the sort of security stories
that we are told by our elected
officials and by media in many cases
they relate to and in many cases justify
the apparatus of capitalism tendencies
towards authoritarianism and they
directly affect our democratic system so
let's first maybe introduce it what are
the security stories that were told well
there are a lot of them and they are
very central narratives in our society
and in our culture right now the as
we're talking the appoint mr. Trump's
appointee for you know Attorney General
is talking about one security narrative
which is very central to the Trump
administration which is the threat that
America has become deeply insecure
because of terrorists and criminals and
rapists and drug offenders
you know crashing through the border and
their caravans and so forth and so one
very dominant form of security story has
to do with foreign enemies who can
create all kinds of security issues
safety problems for the country of
course these tend to come in umbrella
narratives but during the Cold War it
was all about the insecurity that
communism brought to the country and the
whole country got structured around that
security story since 9/11 it's been
shifted more toward terrorism and that's
become the new umbrella it's important
to say that and this is sort of part of
the framing in the book
that the foreign enemy is typically in a
you know one of the ironies of our
security stories is there they are off
and create more insecurity than security
their their design in other words to
produce a sense of insecurity and that
is rooted in I believe very deep and
ancient systems of inequality where
elites people with a lot of power and
the society or a lot of money feel a
need to generate fear or insecurity as a
way of you know gaining attracting
maintaining loyalty from a population
who is getting damaged
being hurt is not getting its fair share
of power wealth and respect in the
society so the foreign enemy story the
security stories often I just wanted to
add a new response to your question
linked to a very important notion of a
kind of Fifth Column enemy linked to the
foreign enemy often who is a domestic
enemy so we have domestic enemies that
can be anything from Muslims now inside
the United States to people of color who
are in some way criminal or you know a
threat to the safety of people in our
cities and country or or to people often
left this in the case of conservative
governments who are threatening our way
of life as immigrants both from outside
and inside doing which is to say that
the the security story is it's more
complex than just the narrative of
adapting to an enemy or somebody who's
threatening our safety but threatening
our whole civilization or sense of
respect and well-being there's a lot of
systems that depend on the
here and the understanding of who it is
that will keep us safe and we've seen
this used effectively for a long time
politically in terms of to sway and
influence voters when it comes to
elections we have that same fear and
belief about what will keep us safe used
to get the sort of sometimes unwilling
acceptance of the surveillance state
from a population again with the belief
that that's a mechanism that will keep
us safe even if it's not rooted in
reality defense contractors and those
who benefit from selling stuff that
supports that security state everything
from the scanners at airports to weapons
and and so much more they benefit from
that status quo so it seems as though
there's actually a number of different
angles from which the establishment
systems benefit from this yes that's
true I mean there there's profitability
in a security state there's I think the
most central issue is maintaining the
legitimacy of the state itself in other
words when people are very very divided
there's always a risk of people uniting
to overthrow the system this goes back
even before capitalist inequalities I
mean if you go back to feudalism you
know the days in the Middle Ages
everybody was told that things were very
dangerous and that the nobility the
kings and queens were given enormous
power because that alone would one make
people safe from all the threats that
satanic were you know the Satan was all
around in a very religious era like that
and also by giving more power to the
elites you were dividing you were giving
more sense of respect and safety to the
population because if your leader was
very powerful enough gave them enough
power to secure your life then you were
more powerful because they lit you out
you were in some way identified with the
leader and you were being divided from
other people within your state who might
be opposing the leader so anyway this
this does profit and benefit many many
different elements in the system in
which is eken
industries which our security endures
you know be there to talk about
surveillance capitalism all the new
digital architecture of global
capitalism has allowed invested in this
there's all the defense industries there
all the politicians who are elected on
fear and so forth Trump has made a
archetypical profession of this but this
goes this preceded Trump it's been true
I mean Reagan talked about the evil
empire it's been the central way in
which elites in the United States have
maintained their authority and sense of
legitimacy yeah I've been using the
example when it comes to this it's
immigration so-called crisis which I've
pointed out a number of times I don't
think the fact to bear out that it is a
an actual crisis that you have as a
talking point the idea that immigrants
both documented and undocumented are
reducing lowering wages in the United
States and taking jobs from American
born citizens and it seems as though
it's an extraordinarily convenient story
and scapegoat which exculpate s-- the
corporation's who are interested in the
cheapest possible labor and who
typically go unpunished for a
contracting that undocumented labor that
seems to be a microcosm and it's not
totally a security story it's also an
economic story of the role of scapegoats
in all of this well the host yeah the
whole story is a combination of I think
it's sort of invented narratives of
security which are economically driven
and politically driven so yeah the
companies have a lot of intruding Trump
you know whose global businesses are all
resting on immigrant labor and cheap
labor from all over the world and this
is a political mechanism a I keep
repeating this but this is a essential
way in which it is in our society elite
corporations with vast economic
interests need to scare people and
divide people in order to maintain their
authority
and the sense of their legitimacy and
there's an enormous money at stake and I
think you point out well that when
you're talking about security narratives
you're talking about more you're talking
about a narrative but you're talking
about an entire economic system and a
political system and this story is one
of the key fabrics for keeping the whole
system intact
can you give a couple of examples of how
these types of security stories can put
us down a path towards if not actual
fascism fascistic authoritarian
ideologies and actions from our leaders
what is what's the path that you see
there well if you look at the book
carefully or not they've just briefly I
have a long chapter on fascism fascism
back in Germany very much is a model of
this kind of thing I mean there was the
foreign threat to Germans who were
suffering enormous economic ordinary
Germans who were suffering a stroke you
know pain after World War one harsh you
know penalties after losing World War
one and Hitler spoke to those as a
result of the Allies who were in fact
imposing strong harsh retribution
against Germany and Hitler could use
that to essentially bring Germans
together around a sense of shared you
know rage about the the popping of
Germany being destroyed by foreign
enemies now Trump is doing something
similar to this right he this is being
symbolized by the wall I think the wall
is a wonderful image
why do you build a wall because you have
enormous presumably because the world is
a dangerous threat there's an invasion
coming show Trump argues that people
coming over the borders or whether it's
in the bands that are going through the
courts now you know I mean the bands
that have been litigated or the wall or
whatever
Trump's entire narrative is around the
dangers that arise one from foreign
threats like Muslim terrorists and
immigrants with nefarious intent
tied to domestic allies
you know liberals who support open
borders or lack of board and some border
security who are not willing to fund the
law Trump says I'm willing to shut down
the government because the most
important thing is to ensure the
security of America now of course most
people understand that the number of
immigrants coming in the United States
has been diminishing very rapidly the
amount of crime that immigrants coming
in is very low and so forth but it's an
incredibly charismatic story it's been
effective in Europe it's been effective
in almost any we've seen I mean it's
important that you raised the issue of
fascism because this is a central threat
of fascism right which is to argue I
mean in Germany Hitler argued it was the
Jews in Germany who were enabling a lot
of this threat from abroad and that Jews
were Jews and other non Aryans in
Germany Slavs and gypsies and so forth
were diluting the threat was not simply
invasion it was dilution of the core
racial identity and creativity you know
Hitler had a very moralistic theory that
only Aryans could bring creative a
spiritual healer was a spiritual
theorist and he argued that and fascism
was really built around very high ideals
of morality and spirituality as Hitler
enunciated them which said that fascism
was the way to maintain the only way to
maintain the spiritual vitality and
essence of the German race and this
became an enormous Lee emotionally
resonant appeal to Germans who were in
desperate appeal you know were
economically decimated and who were
feeling humiliated by the the economic
conditions that have been imposed upon
them so I think we're seeing today with
the extreme inequality United States
with Republican leadership in particular
but it's not simply a Republican thing
it's in both the mainstream political
parties yeah have resorted to this kind
of narrative because we live in an
economic system where
this this kind of extreme inequality is
the way the system operates I mean we're
seeing extreme forms today but if you
look at the work of people like Thomas
Piketty are the most famous global
theorists of inequality over 300 years
of Western capitalism we've seen
consistent very high levels of this kind
of inequality sort of upstairs down
circle is emisn upstairs Downstairs
system much like feudalism before it was
and so security narratives become
central to maintaining the system the
book is called moving beyond fear
appending the security tales in
capitalism fascism and democracy we've
been speaking with the book's author
Charles durbur Charles always great to
talk to you I appreciate it thank you so
much for the conversation I really
appreciate it David